[Applause]
and the first and here we go with paul
george
slithering top with kawhi leonard 04
with his start right now
now the very gritty wrestling matthews
is there with the bump in the drive and
he eases it up and in
being told to shoot six threes a game
but he can make him
he can make them from anywhere on the
floor that's how talented ad
is kawaii takes it right by matthews
with a nice smashing move
oh call davis making the move but right
here it was kawhi with a beautiful
graceful drive
and montrose harrell just laid in his
rotation over
now they have caruso merging with his
energy
kuzma bobbles the ball picked up by the
clippers the other way
george down by as many as 22
outside beverly from leonard retrieved
by pat bev
and back into leonard spin drive offhand
shot is up and in
double figures reggie miller with 10.
how about the beautiful spin move here
on frank vogel's roster
[Music]
here comes kawhi great cut
over gasol got it to go pretty shot
inside and a tough one too makers get
the foul right there moments ago
[Music]
that's over a seven footer let the nba
and assist at ten
time in his career he let it in the nba
in that category he's got two tonight
necklace platoon in the middle it goes
off for george
works on davis so is
12 turnovers for the clippers 11.
nice move there by kawhi leonard comes
kawhi leonard
[Music]
works inside the back of the screen he
finds a couple points
traded in the danny green deal that sent
green to the thunder
and schroeder to the lakers three by
kawhi
is in pretty shot kawhi leonard with a
big three right there
george with a three that's good
[Applause]
matthews who was with milwaukee last
year trying to defend leonard tough
chore
he gets the deuce inside nice play kawhi
with 22
and paul george the other way driving
right by kuzma takes it up and puts it
in
i mean look how effortless this is just
goes right by kuzma
when they signed kuzma to that contract
extension
they've gone nine of 18 combined from
the floor they've got 26 points combined
off the bench this is how they envision
hero to play
for the final stretch of the third
quarter
george three leonard is resting with
22 points on the bench paul george is
getting hot
sign that big contract right before the
season
paul george is hot boy he has had a
string of shots here that have gone in
now with 24.
canard and george and zubots puts on the
brakes puts up a three and now
27. lebron with 22 points that's a three
good 30 on 17 shots and here's the
contact by
caldwell pope down low sending
pg-13 to the line for a four-point play
opportunity
what a tremendous shooting display in
the second half
leonard and davis caruso's on batoon
here comes kauai horton tucker is there
and it goes to kawhi leonard who puts
that shot down
[Applause]
fade away oh what a sweet shot right
there by kawaii for starters out there
and lou williams go off the bench
has tonight put in nine george got it
again
paul george hits another one